[Music]
yardley and zane duffer entered the
previous episode with nocturnal me by
echo and the bunnymen knowing full well
how committed we are to the binge and
they had the audacity to not open this
episode with the killing moon
[Music]
jonathan also nancy is now running
around like she doesn't know she's in
the over easy and then if she wants to
get back to the sunny side up she's got
to crawl back through the gooey tree we
all know the rhyme the one who crawls
through the gooey trees press their luck
and now must flee and if tomorrow you
wish to see crawl your ass back through
that gooey tree also also after running
around in every which direction she
somehow manages to end up at the correct
gooey tree unless there are multiple
gooey trees which would have also been
incredibly convenient oh really because
no girl would ever blow off king steve
okay these stephen king references are
just getting weird at this point also we
wouldn't dare play the music but corey
hart's sunglasses at night was a mega
hit that was released as a single in
1984. therefore it wouldn't be getting
radio airplay near the end of 1983 which
is when the first season of stranger
things takes place
steve will ascend oh so stealthily up to
nancy's window which is all well and
good but if you're trying to be all eye
spy with your late night meetups how
about not leaving your car parked on the
street with the headlights on and the
futuristic singings of one corey hart
blasting out of the radio yeah it was a
drawing of a an adult and a child it
said 11 on it i suppose these two dashes
could be an 11 but you looked at this
for a few seconds and reached this level
of certainty for all you know these
could have been tally marks which would
have made this mean two or it could have
been the letter i twice which would have
made it mean
it was a kid's drawing choice it was
stick figures wasn't will ah yes the old
my kid's a better artist than your kid
defense it's been causing headaches for
all defense attorneys since the stick
figure incident of 1937. i mean what if
this whole time i've been i've been
looking for will i've been chasing after
some other kid hopper chooses to say
this to the mother of the kid he
apparently hasn't actually been looking
for can you just come up here sure but
just in case you're curious that will be
a gun in my pocket you know it can't get
us in here jonathan might be right but
how in the name of the upside down would
he know this jonathan's a dick to
factual reassurance continuing to show
the poster for the thing will not make
it any less of a sin no one had a poster
for the thing in 1983. we're a good 10
years from reassessment and realization
that theater goers were idiots in the
summer of 1982. yeah
having a pen but no paper you know what
a pinnacle paper gets you a smeared name
on your hand that you won't be able to
figure out three minutes later you'll
wonder if that's a lowercase d or
possibly part of an uppercase b but
you'll never know because you forgot the
paper hopper you forgot the paper now
comes the awkward part where jonathan
has to confess he wet the bed because he
was afraid of getting caught in the
hallway by nancy's parents and then
nancy says she knew it happened three
hours ago and then i have no clue which
one of these characters i'm more
concerned about every time i close my
eyes it's like a dark paradise
oh sorry did i just black out in lana
del rey again i hate it when i do that i
mean oh my heart it breaks every step
that it takes damn it it's always alone
like a bear while most species of bears
do generally hunt alone they can exist
and live within close proximity to each
other meaning nancy has no way of
knowing if there are more than one of
these things and it's odd that she's not
even considering that a possibility if
it works at least we'll know what's
coming you have zero knowledge of what
you need to do to protect yourself from
the monster but hey at least that's
similar to a shark theory will be
correct good choices are being made here
i made some blueberry pancakes putting
blueberries in pancakes or adding
anything to them for that matter they're
[ __ ] pancakes why are we messing with
perfect foods your mom does not your mom
doesn't knock see nancy that would have
been the perfect time for your mom jab
everyone in indiana being overly
committed to this one design element
mike this isn't your fault yeah it's
lucas's that's sanctimonist well i hope
so no way i'm not shaking his hand like
i really hope so all three of you were
being a bunch of little [ __ ] dustin
would be the dictator of [ __ ] at tv
sins today is a very special day you're
finally getting a haircut because today
we make history omg he's getting a
haircut today we make contact he's not
getting a haircut karen said she made
blueberry pancakes i made some blueberry
pancakes yet i see no blueberries here
or here i see something that looks like
blueberries here but all the evidence
suggests that she made pancakes and put
blueberries on top of them in all the
ways that matter these are not blueberry
pancakes and once again quit [ __ ]
with pancakes okay
i'll shake i'm really more concerned
about why lucas wasn't immediately
rushed to the hospital dude could have a
concussion or worse after being flung by
11. i know we didn't have will smith
movies telling us the importance of
concussion protocol back in 1983 but
still do you just want to fight the
demogorgon with your wrist rocket i took
r2d2 going to fight darth vader are you
seriously going to act like that
wouldn't be the coolest thing ever q
automatic door opening then rolls in a
battle worn r2d2 has just taken out a
whole battalion no that's too many a
platoon of stormtroopers darth vader
looks down and says i sense no fear in
you and deploys his iconic red
lightsaber suddenly seven green
lightsabers emerge from r2d2's dome and
expand like helicopter blades rocket
boosters emerging from the little robo
legs as they launch head first at darth
vader and a spinning green glowing fury
i'm just saying mike needs to get out of
here with his weak sauce putting your
christmas tree up before thanksgiving
you know you have to pay for those
character had a perfect opportunity to
use lego myego in conversation and chose
not to
ah sudden rachel from pet cemetery but
the
pet cemetery and not the less
pet cemetery i told you you're wasting
your time no you didn't you gave this
cryptic answer but if you want terry to
tell you anything you're about five
years too late and while becky is the
main offender joyce and hopper didn't
ask any follow-up questions why is
everyone in the scene wasting their own
time this show early on has really
undervalued the character of lucas so
seeing him gear up for a one-man mission
to get his friend back is giving me all
of the feels but also getting rambo'd up
in a movie or tv show either made in the
80s or set in the 80s cliche they'd pay
a couple hundred bucks to people like my
sister
gave him drugs
psychedelics lsd mostly
and then they'd strip her naked and put
her in these isolation tanks my awkward
explanation of the plot of altered
states to my mother somehow makes its
way into this episode this is a cool but
unnecessary flashback montage designed
to explain to us everything we've
already put together about 11's past and
since no one in the room has firsthand
knowledge of what happened at the lab
this awkwardly becomes a flashback of
the viewer's experience and i don't like
the creative license they're taking with
my perspective you're gonna need stephen
king the show doesn't care so much
whether or not joyce and hopper have as
much as it wants you to know that the
writers did the handle of this hammer is
just hanging off the edge waiting for
someone to brush by and end up with a
broken toe i feel like we need more
backstory on this guy he just isn't
putting in the effort anymore look at
the signage the two racks on the right
are guns sure but the one on the left is
mostly ammo and raka cooney last week i
was shopping for a new top i thought
steve might like wasting time and money
on clothes you think will make a high
school boy happy you want to make a high
school boy happy show up to where he's
currently at that's it steve and the
rest of the high school cliches were
able to get away with spray painting the
front of the movie theater in the middle
of the day and they hung around
afterwards to face even more property
even if i let go of the fact that they
don't even appear to have a ladder this
scene has more contrived vandalism than
the tate modern also nancy conveniently
pisses off steve on a week that all the
right moves is playing at the local
theater what would he have done if it
was the next week when national
lampoon's movie madness replaced it try
to use a nancy the [ __ ] configuration
with that title he assaulted a police
officer is raising up not realizing
someone is behind you and clipping their
nose with your shoulder really assault i
think the gasoline bullets and bear
traps and jonathan's trunks should be
more concerning but you do you hawkins
police force eating untoasted eggo
waffles
toothless some would say why did they
drop their bikes and run but this was
the correct choice look at that terrain
they'd never get up to speed fast enough
to get away and there are way too many
hazards to navigate the sin here is the
absurd convenience of bulk and skull
showing up out of nowhere to trigger the
conflict that results in eleven also
showing up out of nowhere to save dustin
and mike get up get off me resorting to
murder because you got your ego hurt on
the playground our friend has
superpowers and she squeezed your tiny
bladder with her mind okay show i called
you out for the sheer cruelty of that
scene in episode four but you just owned
it
i get dustin's happy isn't being held at
knifepoint anymore but is he overlooking
the fact that 11 just broke that kid's
arm couldn't she just made the knife fly
away or something despite all the
security measures we know this place has
lucas is not spotted joe thinks the
government in the 80s was combating
conspiracy theories by letting the
public draw conspiracy conclusions
none of us could breathe somewhere under
those bushes was the rest of ray brauer
tommy
how's the peeping
tommy
that's a painting
tell me again
upstairs are downstairs upstairs there
were horses and a man on fire and i
killed a guy with a trident it was a
kid's drawing choice it was stick
figures
wasn't will
meaning it's a predator right there's no
stopping what can't be stopped
no killing what can't be killed your
mind does not we are laughing
wouldn't lie if i were you well if you
were me then i'd be you and i'd use your
body to get to the top you can't stop me
no matter who you are
[Music]
gatsby looked in that moment as if he
had killed a man